you have a film about religion that you
will direct but you say it's not
faith-based yeah it's not a faith-based
film but it's a film about religion yeah
I guess
religion is a subject matter but
faith-based means to me that that it's a
movie it would be a movie that's trying
to get the audience to believe in its
specific religious doctrine because
that's what most
facebait most faith-based films do and
so it's not that it's it's it's not a
film that's not trying to proselytize at
all you know I grew up I grew up in that
world I grew up an evangelical Christian
and so naturally it's something that I
find interesting and I could tell a
specific story about it I thought so
that's why I got interested or decided
to make it and how has it been to argue
to have the film hasn't been released
yet right almost almost I'm in the midst
of color and sound design and all that
sort of stuff but we're almost there
when you were creating the protagonist
for the film did you start with a
problem or a dilemma that needed to be
solved yeah I guess I did I mean I I
knew I wanted to make a film in the
world and I knew I wanted to design it
around a scenario where a character who
is devout goes through a crisis a
character who's only seen or understood
the world in one way is then put into a
situation where it kind of blows up
their worldview I knew that was it the
circumstances of how we got there or
what place they were put in I didn't
know but I knew that's the situation
that I wanted I knew what the character
was like and what kind of situation I
went to put them in what kind of how I
wanted to change their context I guess
how long did it take you to write the
script I wrote the first script of the
first draft of the script ten years ago
Wow so this idea it's called faith or
anything was that the original title
okay
had been probably swirling around and
you all your life maybe yeah I mean well
yeah when you grow up grow up that way I
mean it's gonna inform your your outlook
and certainly inform what you think of
as could be interesting narrative
material and that I had finished the the
documentary and done the festival thing
with it and but new I was like I want to
do I want to do narrative so I sat down
and I had a couple other scripts but I
didn't either one I'm worried they're
good and he could and I want to write
something new and so I sat down and
wrote something new and that's what came
out and then it was a process of okay
that's the first draft of the script I
wrote a couple more drafts of the script
over the next year year and a half and
how am I gonna try to make it and so
what I did which I still recommend to
people I just recommend the students
what I did was I just started looking
for producers who worked in the
independent art space you know they made
like arty American movies cheaply not
things that you know I wasn't sending to
people who were making fifteen million
dollars the movies I'm making I'm
standard the people are making movies
for two million dollars or less and to
see if it not just that but also films
that I liked films that I responded to
the idea being if I'm gonna get the
money to make this I need to make it
cheaply enough because it would be my
first feature and also I you know you
don't want to bark up spend your time
barking up the wrong tree right I'm not
gonna send it to people who are making
low-budget thrillers or low-budget
horror films because it's just not like
nothing wrong with those kinds of films
is is not my Avenue and so I sent it to
lots of people mostly you get ignored
that's kind of the nature of the thing
most time people just don't respond some
nice not for us rejections and then Mike
Ryan was the producer out in New York
and I sent it to him specifically
because he had produced two movies one
called junebug with Amy Adams that I
just loved
while two movies that I love junebug and
then another movie Kelly Reichert second
movie old joy he was a producer on both
of those films and I loved them and they
were in the same style that I wanted to
make this film in and he responded to
the material so but then off we went but
from that period it was still another
six years or so before we actually
started to make the movie it just takes
that long we wrote more drafts got into
some won this thing out in New York
where we got some money people to read
it
Sony Pictures Classics level of the LA
but it still took forever finally we
were able to do it
was that the whole ten-year journey or
was there times when you weren't sure
that this was a topic you want to
explore you always know I'm stubborn as
all hell
so when I said this is a movie I said
this isn't me you know I like I don't
know there's maybe this is complete
arrogance but I feel like I understand
what makes a movie and so that I would
be interested in I guess then you know
sometimes people may not think it's
movie but for me I was like this
position movie and so I was gonna stick
to it and until I got it made now there
were certainly plenty of times when I
was like oh this is never gonna happen I
don't know how this is ever gonna come
together but yeah it wasn't it wasn't
gonna stop you know I think that that's
like when you are in a low-budget space
and you don't have access to all kinds
of money or connections or whatever you
don't have an agency that's backing you
that's gonna you know find the money for
you the one thing you have is your like
your perseverance or your stubbornness
is nobody else you're Sisyphus pushing
the rock up the hill and nobody's gonna
push it up with you so you're just gonna
keep doing it and it's gonna roll back
over on you a bunch of times but that's
that's the one commodity that I could
bring that would be the thing that would
in shirt the movies gonna get made I
couldn't bring the money I couldn't
bring all the connections I can bring
any of that stuff but I could bring that
like I was gonna keep pushing the rock
so yeah and then we ultimately were able
to do it we were able to be able to put
the money together and find some actors
and shoot the film and Brian Geraghty
plays the protagonist
yeah Brian places protagonist Brian is
um Brian's an extraordinary actor he was
an extraordinary actor it was I've
worked with I worked with good actors
before he's the best actor I've ever
worked with it was it was kind of an
amazing thing to watch cuz he's a very
the characters of the characters going
through really rough time and it's a
very quiet film that's a very eating has
to be so so subtle but in that subtlety
showing a lot of pain they're exhibiting
a lot of pain and and Brian is funny and
he's gregarious and he's talkative and
he's jokes and he's a lot of fun on set
and to watch somebody who can switch
from that from joking around and playing
and having a lot of fun to all of a
sudden he's in this moment with a
character who's having to go through
some grief of luncheon grief is
extraordinary thing to watch it's like
the greatest gift to just be able to
point your camera at somebody who can do
that and do it so well it was it was
extraordinary so you're in the editing
phases of it yeah the pictures locked
with it so we're in color and sound and
everything yeah we're done cutting so 10
years 10 years yeah yeah it's but it's
not an uncommon story you know there's
all kinds of people who have that story
of it took me you know 7 8 9 10 years to
finally get a movie made I mean it was
going on a long time and and you know at
one point you know I realized from the
documentary until I don't know I was
probably a couple years into my
relationship with Mike as we were you
know rewriting the film and
and but I'm still feeling like I'm gonna
be able to make this and I look up and
go wow I haven't made anything I haven't
made anything it was it had been I don't
know four five years that I hadn't you
know actually directed I just written
stuff you know and so then I just
started making shorts again like I have
to keep learning I like to keep trying
to become a better filmmaker if I'm
gonna make a feature film I need to make
more films and so I made I mean a series
of shorts over the course of three years
and that was really it was really great
for me it's like get back into the get
back into the habit of making stuff and
get better at it I I think you know you
ask this question about your film
watcher or filmmaker one of the things
that I think that for me makes me want
to keep doing it is it feels like a net
that I could never quite crack is it so
there's so much to do it's so hard to
make to make something that's really
good that really flies it's a never
gonna quite get this right and so you're
just I'm just gonna keep trying to get
it right and so doing it over and over
again you know in just in short form
like I remember somebody said that to a
lot of done with short films when I was
younger
somebody said that and I'm done with
short films I'm going on to a feature
and I thought well yeah that's true we
should you should just move on you
should graduate and now like know like
just whatever you can make if you can
just make youtube videos make youtube
videos because you'll learn doing that
you know after we finished this thing
you know I've got a couple of other
bigger things that I'd like to do but
there it's not well maybe they would
happen right away but I kind of doubt it
and if they don't I'll set up a couple
of shorts and make some more shorts you
know because it will i'll keep learning
by making that's
and the crucial thing that I figured out
while I was doing that
you